bonjour merci d'être avec nous en direct
sur arte france on note donc une
circulation active du virus ces
dernières semaines est ce qu'on peut
dire qu'à une reprise de l'épidémie dans
l'hexagone
il ya plutôt une poursuite de l'épidémie
le virus a toujours circulé sauf que là
il ya il ya une remontée et qui est dû à
un relâchement des mesures de protection
une insuffisance de pour le port du
masque est donc une sorte de relâchement
de la disparition physique et des
mesures de protection donc voilà on
craint que dans les semaines à venir et
à nouveau trop d'hospitalisation et y
compris en réanimation dans pour le
moment c'est la circulation du virus
surtout chez des jeunes avec des formes
peu graves mais il y aura aussi des
formes graves chez les jeunes il faut se
ressaisir pour se ressaisir pour éviter
que le service d'hospitalisation à à
nouveau débordé c'est ça qu'on appelle
une vague
ce sera le cas selon vous dans le cas
d'une seconde vague épidémique mais
j'espère qu'il aura pas de seconde vague
qu'est ce qu'on appelle une seconde
vague on appelle une seconde vague
lorsque le système de santé ne plus
faire ne peut s'occuper que du corps à
la virus que ducobu 19 s'occupe plus des
autres malades et y compris qu'ils
risquent d'être débordés comme on l'a vu
avec des tgv avec bon la situation dans
l'est et dans la région parisienne
alors je pense qu'on arrivera pas là
mais encore faut-il que les mesures de
précaution qui sont répéter répéter soit
respectée il ya une espèce et une partie
minoritaire de la population qu'à un
civisme c'est provocateur même ou
d'inconscience et qui renvoie à
l'individualisme de nos sociétés alors
on demande
il faut qu est-ce qu on vient dans ce
qui est inquiétant c'est que vous dites
qu'on risque d'être débordé et et
services dans les hôpitaux les services
de réanimation risquent d'être débordés
ça voudrait dire quoi que finalement on
n'a pas tiré les leçons de
du plus fort de l'épidémie lorsque tout
le monde était confiné j'espère que nous
c'est à dire que je pense que ça peut
être complètement être évité pour le
moment c'est loin d'être le cas
mais ça augmente et on sait que c'est
exponentiel et on sait qu'il ya toujours
quinze jours trois semaines de délai
pour voir les effets des contaminations
qui se développe alors ou bien ont réagi
collectivement
moi je j'approuve le discours du premier
ministre à un moment donné faut arrêter
d'ergoter faut arrêter de critiquer il
faut faire andy dentelle russe autorisé
pendant tellement d'accord mais on est
intelligent on comprend que dans les
lieux clos
il faut porter un masque
systématiquement et puis dans les lieux
où il ya beaucoup de monde on peut pas
respecté les distances barrières et
d'ailleurs on porte un masque et on
arrête de dire ils ont dit que et c'est
enfin une espèce de jeu d'enfant qui
disent lassés autorisé la savait pas
arrêtons il faut généraliser à dire
l'obligation du port du masque en
extérieur selon vous c'est bien dans les
lieux où il ya beaucoup de monde c'est
évident dans la foule c'est évident dans
l'est que c'est évident il faut
respecter en barrière si vous êtes les
uns contre les autres
eh bien vous avez un risque c'est ses
pattes blancs et noirs cette diminution
du risque par sais pas mais à 100% mais
celui de diminuer le risque donc on
porte le masque à chaque fois que c'est
nécessaire
s'il ya des cas du monde est évidemment
dans les lieux clos et puis par contre
il est seul dans la rue seul sur une
plage seul en forêt vous avez pas besoin
de porter de masque mais ça y'a pas
besoin d'être très intelligent pour
comprendre il ya un petit jeu qui les
consignes sont pas claires
or on dit des choses contradictoires
arrêtons ce petit jeu on est intelligent
on comprend très bien que dans telle rue
saint c'est pas autorisé
il est très bien la rue d'à côté il ya
autant de monde et dans le porte encore
alors là vous en appelez on comprend
bien à votre message à la responsabilité
des citoyens mais sur la question des
tests l'accès des tests à l'ensemble de
la population qu'elles sont là vos
observations est ce que
il n'y a pas là justement ce n'est pas
de limiter pour pouvoir se faire tester
aujourd'hui en france comme on nous
l'avait annoncé
alors je vais vous dire ce que disent
mes collègues spécialistes je suis pas
spécialiste je peux infectiologues
mais ce que disent mes collègues ses
comptes est trop tard trois quatre jours
de délai il faut tester tout de suite
desquels les premiers symptômes ou qu'on
a été en contact avec quelqu'un qui
était contaminée donc il faut tester
tout de suite sans attendre et il faut
que les résultats arrivent dans la
journée alors visiblement on a des
progrès à faire
bon donc vous c'est un des sujets sur
lequel on doit progresser
et pourquoi est-ce qu'on a encore un
niveau bas dans leur rapidité pour qu'on
pourra les faire tester et ensuite dans
la de donner des résultats
parce que si vous êtes positif et bien
vous devez demi à l'isolément pour que
de casser comme on dit les chaînes de
contamination donc si on attend trois
jours quatre jours est la réponse là le
virkus vous transmettez le virus à tous
les gens que vous rencontrez
donc il a il ya un problème d'efficacité
ça suppose que les personnes le
comprenne je vais me tester tout de
suite et ça suppose qu'on ait des moyens
humains au laboratoire pour faire les
tests et puis ensuite qu'on en tire les
conclusions passé et pas seulement de
rester un il faut tracer tous les
contacts et il faut isoler et à ce
moment là on est efficace donc je crois
qu'il ya une chose qui est absurde qui
est le message c'est dire des jeunes
c'est pas dangereux pour eux c'est pas
vrai c'est beaucoup moins dangereux mais
c'est pas 0 il ya eu des joints de moins
de 50 ans qui sont morts il ya des
séquelles
bon donc on va attendre combien il faut
combien de personnes de moins de 50 ans
gravement touché pour qu'on en dise non
y étant non parce que le premier
ministre a raison 1
il faut en appeler à civic et à un
comportement citoyen et puis si il faut
il faut des sanctions
en face et je serai triste d'en arriver
sanctions pour les gens comprennent que
la société doit se protéger
merci à vous andré grimaldi je rappelle
que vous êtes professeur émérite
diabétologie au chu pitié-salpétrière
coauteur de santé urgences merci